there's something about pulling your
pants down and keeping your sneakers on
and just cranking it out that's so
[ __ ] pathetic
i'm paul verzi and i am here to answer
the internet what's the worst drunk food
you can eat after a night of drinking
um
oh man it's two i ate it at a street
meat truck twice because i was blacked
out and i didn't realize i went the
first time
so i was so hammering twice in one night
i ate
twice in an hour i was blacked out drunk
i went to one of those street meat
trucks i had like yeah put the white
sauce in the hot sauce ate the whole
thing got to like two blocks and said to
my friend dude are you hungry and went
back to it and did that so that was a
real bad mistake and i and also i think
um mcdonald's when you're hammered
because you just overdo it because it's
so delicious so those are the ones those
are the worst for me uh would you rather
have a girl who talked a lot during sex
sex or a girl who was completely silent
during it uh i would definitely
definitely take the talking dude because
if you're just silent i'm gonna be like
something's wrong somewhere like i did
something wrong or she's [ __ ] up this
doesn't feel right i would just have you
know rather have somebody yap in her
mouth because at least i know she's like
into it and really like participating
talk to me about anything but being dead
silent would be like is this a [ __ ]
serial killer if you could make any two
people
fight in a no rules cage match
who would you choose it would have to
just be just because he's polarizing it
would have to be trump
and uh
it would be trump and de blasio oh wow
it would be trump and de blasio just
because
one group and one side is gonna be so
happy and and the other person is going
to maybe deserve it if that makes sense
that the bases are so
rabid and not only that like the winner
is going to be just if that makes sense
so it would be
de blasio versus trump in a kate no
rules
oh my god i might have to go donny t
just because i don't think de blasio
doesn't look like he's got the athletic
bone what is one thing that somebody can
say that makes you immediately hate them
um oh my god there's a lot
there there's there's a lot uh i would
say um
when when somebody offensive
if somebody says the word that's
offensive or isn't that offensive or
isn't that i'm just like you can't be
talked to you're not an adult you don't
understand how the world works and you
hear a buzzword because you're a [ __ ]
child
if you got 10 000
a day for every day you didn't
masturbate
how many days would you last
uh
i mean i'm
i'm not i'll be honest with you i'm not
a big i don't crank them out a lot like
i because here's the thing dude i
something happened to me as i got older
it's gonna be weird but i'm just gonna
[ __ ] say it
okay
there's something about pulling your
pants down
and and your boxer briefs and keeping
your sneakers on and just cranking it
out that's so [ __ ] pathetic
ridiculous and it's you it's me like i'm
i'm getting myself it's me do you
understand what i'm saying nobody ever
thinks of that it's like it's not like
oh i'm going to have sex i'm going to go
like don't get me wrong i've been
psyched a couple times when it's been a
while but at the end of the day
like you just like you get psyched
you're like oh dude tonight it's uh you
know but at the end of the day it's
[ __ ] me just pulling my [ __ ] and it's
like it's kind of [ __ ] ridiculous and
pathetic so sometimes when i'm about to
do it i'm like dude you know it's you
and i'm just like yeah i'm just not i'm
good with not so so i would say like
yeah i don't i'm not a big occasion so
could you go like you know 50 days in a
row no i would have like 50 days i would
be like i would tell my wife at 50 i'd
be like stace come here because i don't
want to do something embarrassing to
myself so why don't you
why don't you jump in here
uh if you could only watch one actor's
movies for the rest of your life who
would it be al pacino hands down no
questions asked scarface but for me the
transformation of a shy soldier
in godfather to mike to michael corleone
being where he's killing every head of
the and watching that transformation in
the acting and for me the one scene that
got me with al pacino forever was
when he is in the restaurant and he's
got to shoot them and he goes in to get
the gun the way he's thinking before the
way his eyes are moving and he knows
like they obviously don't know but he
knows he's gonna do this thing and is it
gonna go as planned and he's nervous and
he's thinking about it it really made me
think oh [ __ ] this guy's gonna do it and
i just love and i've also heard stories
about how great he is and how sweet of a
person he is so for me um even though
there's other people's movies for me it
would be pacino it says would you rather
go back to being 18 years old knowing
everything i know now
or get a million dollars so that means
that i get a million now
or i could go back to 18 oh
i would
i would take i'm happy with my life i
would you know my kids i would take the
million now
and i would just use those things as i
wouldn't want to go back and let's say
let's say you know you if you go back to
18 it's not like you would miss your
kids or whatever you like you work back
there and it's not like you're missing
your old life okay your brain's been
like wiped clean or whatever it's more
just that you would have the knowledge
that you have now
business-wise and and social wise and
all that
that's a tough one because i love the
experiences from 18 including the
fuck-ups because i think that that's
what needed to happen yeah i'm going to
do that i'm going to stay here and i'm
going to take a tax-free
yeah yes
that was such an attack listen is it
listen are the feds taking anything if
the feds are taking anything we got it
no no i would say i'll take a cool
million right now and go with my life
experiences and and try to make that
work all right if you had
uh if you had one uh
free throw
and if you make it you get a million
dollars but if you miss it you never get
to text again would you shoot it holy
[ __ ]
um
i
i
i would definitely one thousand percent
no questions asked look at me internet
okay look at me
100
i would take that shot and it would be a
[ __ ] bucket
period it would be a bucket when my son
went to camp and he went to knicks camp
that they've been doing for 29 years
they had a parent come out and have to
shoot you get all these gifts and on the
last one i did and i just without
hesitation knocked it down and we just
got loaded with gifts and i looked at my
son i was like we think i was gonna miss
it
you'll [ __ ] miss it
would you would you make that same bet
but your son's got to shoot the free
throw do you have the faith that he's
hitting it yeah yeah yeah because my
sons get you know i do i actually do
think that he would hit it
it's all about the elbow and the follow
uh i love how i'm saying i'm 5 8 and
italian and greek and i'm like it's
about to follow i tell dick jokes and
moles
which whoa
would you rather watch your dad [ __ ] a
hundred year old woman
watch your mother kill someone
[Music]
that should just win the internet that
that's uh
i i got oh my god dude i would watch my
mother kill somebody dude i can't watch
my dad just bang out a [ __ ]
century-old chick
dude
like they say when you're 80 don't fall
cause you'll break a hip i'm not gonna
watch my dad [ __ ] some no i would
watch my mom take somebody out and it
would be kind of like a
a cool memory like to be like dude i
lived through a lot i've seen a lot i
had kids but i saw my mother take
somebody out i would definitely do that
what if it's like she like strangles
someone like but the worst way would be
the worst way to watch your mom kill
someone i think like like her holding
somebody in water and i would be like
or what about this what about watching
your mom just dump gasoline on somebody
tied and lighting it's like mom my mom
dude what the [ __ ] mom just [ __ ]
shoot him shoot him like like if my mom
was like hold on because if here's the
thing about burning somebody dead you
got to do extra [ __ ] like it's not just
like you gotta you gotta like go back
you gotta do you gotta have matches like
you gotta [ __ ] like lead up to it
like like some [ __ ] yeah so if my mom
started doing [ __ ] like that but i would
definitely
that would be a better memory than my
dad doing that to a hundred-year-old
woman
all right big thanks to paul versey for
coming through he absolutely killed it
although i think he also killed
masturbation straight up murdered my
favorite pastime paul there's no way i'm
going to ever be able to jerk off again
without being embarrassed with myself if
you want to see paul live and in person
he's filming his new special saturday
september 18th at the west niagara
comedy club click here to buy tickets
you're going to want to see this dude in
person check it off the bucket list he's
one of the best in the game get your
tickets right now click here to buy